as foundations for nation states
religious nationalism and secular
nationalism are often thought of as
polar opposites those who value secular
nationalism often depict religious
nationalism as backward irrational
repressive and violent
in contrast secular nationalism is
depicted as modern rational liberal and
peaceful on the other hand those who
value religious nationalism often depict
secular nationalism as immoral
individual and a vestige of colonialism
while religious nationalism is
represented as moral communal and a form
of self-determination all of these
depictions perpetuate common
misunderstandings of both religion and
secularism in reality religious
nationalism and secular nationalism are
umbrella terms that include incredibly
diverse ideologies their values can be
overlapping or in opposition depending
on social and historical context for
example in 1923 the Republic of Turkey
was formed as a secular state following
the fall of the Ottoman Empire its first
president Kemal Ataturk brought in
sweeping reforms that replaced Muslim
rule and culture with a particular form
of secularism by the 1970s
Turkey was the most secular of all
Muslim majority countries but rampant
inequality and the perception of
government corruption gave rise to
Islamic parties that gained enough power
by 1996 to form a coalition government
in response secular officials imposed a
public ban on a symbol of Islam the
headscarf
women who wore the hijab were no longer
allowed to study at the University and a
democratically elected member of
parliament named Marva kavacha
representing the Islamic virtue party
was prevented from taking the
both of office by her fellow secular
National Assembly members when she
entered the Parliament they stood and
yelled out for 30 minutes until she was
forced to leave two weeks later she was
stripped of her Turkish citizenship
these and related restrictions
emboldened members of Islamic political
parties and the current president Recep
air Dewan is an Islamist who was held
power since 2003 in another example the
United States is a secular nation but
it's currency is imprinted with In God
We Trust the Pledge of Allegiance
includes the phrase one nation under God
and 42 of the 45 US presidents
identified as Protestant Christians
India is also a secular nation but over
the past few decades democratically
elected Hindu nationalists have gained
power they enacted reforms in education
and culture that promote particular
forms of Hinduism that many other Hindus
and members of other religious and
secular communities find troubling like
all worldviews religious and secular
forms of nationalism can only be
understood in their particular social
and historical contexts understanding
their rich diversities will enhance our
understanding of movements on local
national and international levels
you
you
you